Denise doesn't you know at this point
when compared to these athletic guys in
MMA today we saw with Matt Hughes you
know you know he couldn't compete
anymore once people sort of knew the
tricks but um yeah I mean that it's very
humbling the whole experience was even
crazier Hickson hoist is brother yeah
boys will tell you he's 10 times better
than him yeah Hickson would do to hoist
what hoist would do to other black belt
what was in that sort of vehicles
the story was they could have had hexam
but he was too athletic and too you know
there was a bunch of issues and I would
not want to say exactly what happened
for fear of upsetting either side
because I think there's two different
stories okay but he was essentially the
champion of the family and one of the
thoughts was that it would be more
impressive if hoist did it because hoist
was only 175 pounds and yeah with his
shirt off he looked like he was fit but
look like a volleyball player captain
right
whereas Hicks like Freddie Mercury
Hickson was shredded hexam was like
really into physical training he did a
lot of gymnastics and yoga he was yeah
but he was also like way physically
stronger
it would appear more that he was just
dominating some like a cat yeah jumping
so wasn't as good of an advertisement
for it wasn't necessarily true though
because it was also talked that no one
can control Hicks and it didn't want
Hickson to win because Hickson is a he's
like a free spirit like in the greatest
sense of the word like legitimately he
might throw his phone in the ocean to
disappear for a month and just fucking
surf and do jiu-jitsu somewhere oh he's
a freak in the best sense of the word
that's awesome so I don't think they
ever thought they could control Hickson
that was part of the the problem with
having Hicks and be the champion
Hicks it would probably freeze up the
whole organization I want 10 million
dollars on hero fight again like they
were offering him fights for years and
he had some crazy number that he wanted
and he was like if you give me that
number I'll fight phaidor if you give me
that number I'll fight the best fighters
oh yeah it's sander after the right yes
after the UFC started but everybody
still knew see when hoist was winning
everyone still knew Hickson was
competing in something called Japan
Valley tudo and he won that and you got
to see that super high level Jiu Jitsu
pride one was Hickson and
Hickson was the guy that everybody knew
that if something happened and then
hoist was out of the UFC or there was no
other Gracie's in the UFC Hickson is
always there to step in and we were
always wondering when he's gonna step
out when's he gonna fight the best
happens never did know he fought some he
fought Funaki who was a really
high-level guy that was his last fight
and he strangled him put him to sleep
it's a crazy image man of him rear naked
choke Funaki and four knocked his eyes
roll in the back of his head he goes
unconscious and Hickson just throws him
off